hi uh steve here i just thought i would
uh
get on and do a short video to explain
the
the previous one
uh
it was a video in russian
i have a blog at eckharmos v which has
been my great source of of russian
listening and reading over the last uh
year or so
and i have a blog there and i normally
write
for that blog and it's a rather long
process because my russian is so full of
holes that what i have to do is i have
to write it and i it takes me a while to
write it and then i have to send it in
to one of our tutors at link to have
them correct it and then i get it back
and it doesn't necessarily come back
right away
and so it takes a while before it gets
up there everyone's very impressed with
how good my russian is but of course
that's because it's corrected by our
tutors
so anyway that's what all that is about
but uh while i have uh this video going
i might comment on a few things there's
been some discussion at one of our link
forums about how useful a tutor is
and one of our
members who's actually a teacher sort of
implied that a teacher or a tutor is
superfluous
and i just want to comment on that i am
very much of a motivated self-learner
uh
you can see that if you remember at link
i'm one of the heavy users i create a
lot of links i also use tutors a lot now
for speaking and also for my writing
correction
but i'm an independent learner much more
independent learning
much more and of an independent learner
than most
i like having a tutor uh not so much at
the beginning
again because i know what i'm doing i've
learned 11 languages i know how to go
about it i think a person who is less
confident or less knowledgeable as a
language learner should have a tutor
earlier the tutor is someone who
encourages inspires
someone that you don't want to let down
someone who can explain things
occasionally
uh tutors too at link it's it's pretty
wonderful when i see the work that
rasana one of our tutors is doing for me
in russian and some of the same stuff is
happening in other languages japanese
german and so forth spanish
french
but rosanna will
talk for two three minutes about cases
and give many examples or she'll talk
about verbs of motion in other words
she'll provide an explanation
which is an excellent explanation and
and might be the kind of explanation
that you would get in class
except that everyone who is a member at
lincoln is studying russian can
grab that explanation from the library
listen to it read it save words and
phrases from it listen to it over and
over again
and so we're leveraging the tutor in
that way but yeah you need people to
help you out i think
i very much appreciate getting my
writing corrected
i'll sometimes record my corrected
writing
which helps to reinforce it so i i think
the tutor as long as it's not
you know i uh then i'll digress there
was some discussion i had a discussion
with
someone here in the canadian government
about
the possibility of of link getting
involved in some of the immigrant
learning that takes place and
of course they were quite negative on
the idea and i'll get into that later
but one of the questions was what are
the credentials of your teachers
well rosanna to take an example
she is an i.t professional in
magnitogorsk in the euros
she's phenomenal
the reports that i get from our
discussions
very much in detail she explains a bunch
of stuff about the grammar more than i
need which is fine because it's all
content to me
she has no credentials as a teacher
if i have a choice between someone who's
enthusiastic pleasant helpful
has empathy
enjoys it
versus someone who has a degree in
philology
linguistis and i don't know what
i don't need that
and and i'm not saying that the person
with those degrees can't be a good
teacher that person may very well be an
excellent teacher
but it's more a matter of personality
uh i said somewhere that a good teacher
has to be a performer
uh so the credentials are almost
irrelevant i think you'll probably find
the same percentage of people
who
just by their nature can be a good
teacher you'll find them in every walk
of life
not necessarily just amongst people who
have taken a course in teaching
uh
so yeah i think a tutor a friend a coach
an advisor a guide
you know a sounding board
that kind of role
uh is important so that's on the issue
that we discussed on our on our
forum at link another issue that that is
a part of the discussion i had with the
canadian government was
that their
uh program for immigrants is based on a
thing called the canadian language
benchmarks and there is a wikipedia
entry for that and i looked it up and
the canadian language benchmarks is in
turn
based on a thing called task based
language learning which also has a
wikipedia wikipedia entry
and
as i understand it task-based language
learning means having people do tasks in
class
uh let's pretend that we are
going to the bank
let's pretend that uh
you know you're going through customs or
whatever it might be
and supposedly this gets people to use
the language and
and that's very good
now that might be very good
um i happen to believe in in a lot of
input initially with a minimum amount of
output in the initial stages as you
accumulate your words and phrases and
familiarity with everything that happens
in the language
but there are people who like output
that's fine
the problem i have with that is that the
canadian government
will only support
language programs for immigrants based
on
canadian language benchmarks
based on uh so-called task-based
language learning
in other words based on a system which
only works in a classroom
so
those people who don't like to learn
that way
those teachers who don't like to teach
that way they're out of luck everybody
has to learn the one way
i find that astounding
uh i have never suggested that everybody
should use link and only use link
i've suggested that link is a useful way
to learn
i think it is a more natural way to
learn not just link but input based
learning is less stressful more cost
effective it puts the onus on the
learner where it should be
it gives the uh the learner a lot of
freedom of choice and learn and use dead
time during the day and so forth and so
on but
to suggest that all public funds
available
for language learning
should be applied to one system only
that people don't have the choice to
learn
some other way and be supported by the
government is nothing short of
astounding uh it's it's it's like what
happened to choice anyway
so uh but this was just a quickie here
just to comment on why you had that
russian video that preceded this one
and uh thank you for listening bye for
now